Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Vous voulez réaliser des choses qui vous
paraissent complètement impossibles ?
Super facile.
Vous n’avez qu’à devenir magicien.
Vous avez peut-être déjà
entendu cette phrase.
Moi, en tout cas, oui,
je l’ai entendue des dizaines de fois.
Alors, à force, j’ai décidé de le devenir.
Je m’appelle Ben Aymeric,
j’ai 24 ans, je suis magicien
et consultant en communication.
Quand j’étais plus jeune,
comme beaucoup de gens,
j’étais quelqu’un
d’extrêmement timide, fermé.
Je ne savais pas trop comment
communiquer avec les autres,
engager un simple sujet de discussion,
même appeler quelqu’un au téléphone,
me paraissait complètement impossible.
C’était frustrant car j’avais envie
de parler avec les autres,
d’échanger, de partager,
mais je n’avais pas la méthode.
Alors, comment ?
Comment avoir confiance en soi ?
Comment susciter l’intérêt chez l’autre ?
Comment attirer l’attention ?
Et une fois qu’on a cette attention,
comment la maintenir ?
Il fallait que je trouve une méthode
pour changer
ma façon de communiquer avec les autres.
Cette même méthode qui me permet
de parler devant vous aujourd’hui.
Alors, j’ai cherché pendant des semaines
et j’avoue ne pas avoir
trouvé grand-chose.
Mais je suis quelqu’un qui
croit beaucoup au destin.
Alors, j’ai laissé les choses se faire
et quelques jours plus tard,
alors que j’étais avec des amis,
mes parents, dans un petit restaurant,
un magicien vient nous voir à notre table
et passe dix minutes avec nous.
Dix ans plus tard, je serai incapable
de vous dire le nom de ce magicien,
comment il était habillé
car ce qui m’a marqué ce soir-là,
c’est les réactions incroyables de
toutes les personnes autour de la table
et cette question qu’on s’est tous posée
au moins une fois dans la soirée :
Comment est-ce possible ?
Cet homme qui est arrivé de nulle part,
que personne ne connaissait,
est venu à notre table
avec 52 bouts de papier.
Dessus, il y avait des symboles pique,
cœur, trèfle, carreau.
Il a passé dix minutes avec nous.
Il est parti et tout le monde
s’est rappelé ce moment.
Pour moi, ça a été le déclic.
Moi, je veux être comme cet homme
et je veux devenir magicien.
Alors, j’ai appris les mécanismes
de la magie, les trucs, comme on dit.
Je me suis entraîné sur les autres élèves
de mon collège, même dans mon lycée.
Et là, je prenais confiance en moi.
Je suscitais l’intérêt chez l’autre.
J’arrivais à attirer l’attention
et j’arrivais à la maintenir,
cette attention.
J'avais enfin trouvé ma méthode
pour mieux communiquer.
Alors, j’ai continué à travailler jusqu’à
atteindre un niveau professionnel.
Et à côté de ça, j’ai fait des études
en communication
car je voulais comprendre
comment ça fonctionnait
cette histoire de communication.
Et comme je n’aime pas faire
les choses sans intérêt,
j’ai mis tout ce que j’apprenais
en communication dans ma magie.
Ça m’a permis,
et ça me permet encore d’ailleurs,
de travailler un peu partout en France,
dans des endroits incroyables,
en rencontrant des personnes
exceptionnelles.
Et avec beaucoup de recul,
je peux vous avouer un petit secret.
La magie permet de mieux communiquer
grâce aux émotions.
Alors, je sais, vous allez me dire :
«Normalement, un magicien ne dévoile pas
un secret, ça ne se fait pas. »
Mais celui-là me tient à cœur
et je suis très content de pouvoir
le partager avec vous.
Et donc, je vais vous expliquer
comment la magie peut permettre
de changer votre façon de communiquer.
Mais d’abord, pensons-nous à la même chose
quand on parle de magie ou de magicien ?
Au fur et à mesure des années,
je me suis aperçu que
les personnes que j’ai rencontrées
avaient une définition vraiment propre
de ce qu’était la magie ou le magicien,
mais complètement différente de la mienne.
J’ai souvent entendu cette phrase :
« Finalement, magicien, illusionniste,
prestidigitateur, c’est pareil, non ?»
Ben non, ce n’est pas pareil.
Dans la langue française,
il y a certes beaucoup de mots qui veulent
souvent dire exactement la même chose,
mais là, c’est différent et je vais vous
expliquer comment je les différencie.
Dans un premier temps,
il y a le prestidigitateur.
Étymologiquement,
ça vient du latin «preste», agilité
et «digitus », le doigt.
C’est donc un acteur qui a cette capacité
à pouvoir faire des performances,
à manipuler des objets de façon
très forte, avec une certaine dextérité.
Et vous, en tant que spectateur, eh bien,
vous êtes fasciné de voir ça
et vous applaudissez un certain travail,
une certaine agilité.
Et vous dites :
«Waouh, c’est fort, ce qu’il fait.
Comment fait-il ?»
Ho, je récupère celle-là, j’en ai besoin.
Mais voilà ce qu'est le travail
du prestidigitateur.
Ensuite, il y a l’illusionniste.
Ça vient du latin «illudio»,
qui est celui qui trompe ou se joue de.
C’est donc un acteur qui a cette capacité
à pouvoir tromper ce que vous voyez,
ou jouer avec votre perception du réel.
Et ça, en tant que spectateur,
ça vous fascine de voir qu’on arrive
à manipuler votre regard,
votre façon de voir les choses,
mais c’est pour du divertissement.
Par exemple, vous pourriez avoir
l’illusion qu’il y a un jeu de cartes,
alors qu’en réalité,
il n’y a qu’une seule carte.
Ça, c’est du travail de l’illusionniste.
Et enfin, il y a le magicien.
Celui qui, littéralement, a cette capacité
de pouvoir provoquer de la magie.
Très bien, mais la magie, c’est quoi ?
Eh bien, la magie,
ce n’est pas un tour de cartes.
Si vous ouvrez un dictionnaire,
par exemple celui du Petit Robert,
à la définition de magie,
vous verrez qu’il y en a plusieurs,
dont une qui est magie, deux points,
impressions fortes,
virgule, inexplicables.
Et moi, ça me fait penser à la phrase
d’un célèbre magicien qui disait :
«La magie ne se trouve pas
dans les mains du magicien,
mais dans l’œil de celui qui regarde.»
Ça veut dire que,
la magie n’est pas la disparition
à proprement parler d’un jeu de cartes,
mais c’est la réaction que
ça va provoquer chez vous, spectateurs,
et qui va déclencher une certaine émotion
et qui peut vous faire poser cette
question du « Comment c’est possible ? »
La magie, c’est donc un état inexplicable
qui se dégage en vous,
la plupart du temps sous forme d’émotions.
Et contrairement à la prestidigitation
ou à l’illusionnisme qui sous-entendent
l’utilisation d’un truc ou d’un artifice
que l’on manipule
dans le but de divertir une audience,
eh bien, le magicien, lui,
c’est celui qui a cette capacité
à pouvoir provoquer
des émotions chez les gens
sans laisser la place à une possible
explication rationnelle.
Alors, c’est peut-être encore quelque
chose de flou pour vous,
mais voici un exemple qui m’est arrivé
il n’y a pas très longtemps.
Il va vous faire comprendre
comment cette magie
peut être présente dans votre quotidien.
On met les choses dans le contexte.
C'était il y a quelques semaines.
J'étais dehors.
Il faisait nuit.
J’ai voulu observer l’espace,
parce que l’espace,
c’est quelque chose qui me fascine.
Quand j'ai levé les yeux au ciel,
j'ai vu les étoiles.
Et là, pendant 5, 10 secondes,
j’ai eu ce silence.
Et puis j’ai eu cette phrase :
«Waouh, c’est magique !»
Pourtant, à ce moment-là,
aucun magicien n’est apparu
et qui m’a dit : «Tiens, choisis
une carte, je vais la retrouver.» Non !
C’est quelque chose qui s’est déclenché
en moi, quelque chose d’inexplicable.
Et c'était magique.
C’est drôle car un peu plus tard,
j’étais sur mes réseaux sociaux
et je tombe sur la photo d’une amie,
celle-ci, qu’elle a légendée par :
«Magique Cosmic».
Et là, encore une fois, je regarde,
je n’ai pas de carte, pas de truc,
pas d’artifices,
juste une émotion
qui se dégage dans cette photo.
D’ailleurs, les émotions, parlons-en.
C’est super important pour moi, l’émotion,
j’ai besoin de voir
ces émotions sur les gens.
Mais j’ai beau travailler avec elles
depuis des années,
je serais incapable de vous donne
une définition claire et commune, surtout,
de ce qu’est l’émotion.
L’émotion, c’est tellement
propre à chacun,
ça se déclenche tellement différemment
que je ne pourrais pas vous dire :
«L’émotion, c’est ça.»
Je prends un exemple : le feu.
Imaginez la première personne qui
a pris deux cailloux et les a frottés.
Elle y a découvert le feu.
Je suis sûr qu’elle n’a pas du tout eu
la même réaction que vous aujourd’hui.
Cette personne, elle a peut-être eu
de l’incompréhension, une certaine peur.
Elle a peut-être pleuré
le jour où elle a vu ça,
alors que vous, j’ai vu des rires,
un peu de surprise,
c’est tout, quoi.
Vous n’avez pas le même vécu.
Et encore, je ne parle pas de ce moment
assez incroyable
où vous allumez un briquet
et voyez une flamme,
ça sort d’un bout de plastique,
et vous, ça ne vous choque pas ?
Bref, même si je ne peux pas définir
cette notion d’émotion,
le gros avantage,
c’est qu’on peut voir les émotions
sur les gens.
Il y a une photo que j’aime
énormément, c’est mon filleul,
et là, cette émotion,
on la voit : la joie.
Ces émotions, on peut les voir
et on peut les donner aux autres.
Quand j’ai eu cette phrase,
quand j’en ai discuté avec des amis,
un ami m’a dit :
«Oui Ben, mais moi, je n’arrive pas
à montrer mes émotions.
Je n’y arrive pas. Je ne sais pas faire.»
J’ai rigolé car tous les jours,
il m’envoie des messages
et dans tous ses messages et textos,
il y a une émotion.
Certes, je ne la vois pas sur son visage,
mais il m’envoie une représentation
visuelle de l’émotion.
Vous les connaissez sûrement,
mais si je devais les mettre
en application sur mon filleul... Ouf !
La joie.
Très belle représentation.
Mais il y a aussi la confiance.
Une certaine surprise.
La peur, la tristesse.
La colère, le dégoût.
Les émotions comme ça, des représentations
visuelles de l’émotion,
il y en a des dizaines.
On ne les compte même plus.
Et en fait, tout le monde
les utilise au quotidien,
visuellement ou via des messages.
Vous appellerez ça comme vous voulez,
des émotions, des émoticônes, des emojis,
je m’en fiche.
Ce qu’il faut comprendre,
c’est que ces émotions donnent une
information complémentaire à un message.
Et pas des moindres.
C’est le ressenti.
Je pense qu’on est tous d’accord,
pour les utilisateurs réguliers de
ces émotions visuelles,
comme moi ou cet ami,
avec et sans, le message n’a pas
tout le temps le même sens.
Ça nous prouve une chose, c’est que faire
passer un message avec une émotion,
ça permet que ce message
ait une importance différente,
qu’il soit plus fort,
qu’il ait un impact plus fort.
D’ailleurs, la première fois qu’on a eu
une représentation visuelle de l’émotion,
c’était dans le cadre d’une entreprise
où les dirigeants voulaient
remonter le moral des salariés à la sortie
de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale.
Ils ont fait le premier smiley.
Ça a marché.
Les gens allaient mieux.
Comme quoi une simple représentation
d’une émotion
génère déjà une certaine émotion.
C’est un peu comme quand on vous dit :
« Le sourire au téléphone, ça s’entend. »
C’est ce qu’on appelle l’émotion positive.
Bon, on va faire un petit récap.
La magie, c’est cette capacité à pouvoir
provoquer une émotion chez quelqu’un.
Et l’émotion.
Eh bien, c’est ce ressenti qu’on peut
avoir et qu’on peut donner avec un message
et qui permet de mieux le retenir.
Ça crée un souvenir.
Par exemple, j’ai un souvenir
dans un coin de ma tête
depuis des années maintenant,
bientôt dix ans.
C'est cette carte que j'ai signée.
Il y a trois choses marquantes
qui sautent peut-être aux yeux.
La première, c’est que pour vous,
c’est un simple bout de papier
plié en quatre et qui n’a aucun sens.
La deuxième, c’est que je garde dans
un coin de ma tête ma propre signature.
La dernière, c’est que
c’est un bout de papier,
dans un coin de ma tête depuis des années,
mais le souvenir que j’en ai est intact,
il n’a pas bougé.
Je me rappelle encore toutes ces choses
folles qui sont arrivées
alors que j’ai choisi juste un 9 de cœur
qu’on m’a fait signer.
Et puis, d’un coup, c’est parti en live,
à droite, à gauche,
il s’est passé des choses folles
sous mes yeux
alors que c’était ma propre signature.
Et cette carte, elle a même fini pliée
en quatre dans ma poche.
Et ce souvenir, il est comme
figé dans le temps,
même après toutes ces années.
Alors, comment la magie peut-elle
transformer un simple message ou objet
en quelque chose de mémorable ?
Pour comprendre ça,
il suffit de comprendre comment
fonctionne la communication.
Je vais vous montrer
un schéma très simple.
De la communication
vraiment basique, basique.
On a un émetteur, un récepteur
et au milieu, un message.
Cet émetteur, il va encoder ce message
qui va passer via un canal,
que ce soit la voix, un média,
ce qu’on veut.
Il va être décodé par le récepteur
qui lui va après l'interpréter.
Ça, c'est la façon la plus basique
de représenter la communication.
Je vous passe toutes les petites choses
qui peuvent interférer.
Maintenant, comment ce message
peut-il devenir extraordinaire,
créer une certaine magie,
et provoquer des émotions ?
Il faut que ce message touche
directement votre récepteur,
et notamment l’affect.
Il faut que cette personne puisse
se reconnaître dans vos propos,
qu’elle puisse s’identifier,
que ça puisse lui rappeler des choses.
Et à ce moment-là, je pourrais faire
évoluer le schéma de cette façon-là.
On a toujours notre émetteur,
notre récepteur, notre message.
Sauf que là, l’émetteur,
via une certaine technique,
va donner un message
qui touche directement à l’affect.
Forcément, en arrivant chez le récepteur,
ça lui rappelle des choses
et provoque cette magie.
En provoquant cette magie,
ça provoque des émotions.
Et ces émotions vont être reliées,
associées à ce message.
En faisant ça, il y a plus de chances
qu'on se souvienne de ce message.
Et ça, je pense que ce n’est pas
seulement propre au métier de magicien,
d’illusionniste ou de prestidigitateur,
mais que ça peut s’appliquer
à tous les domaines.
Prenez l’humoriste avec ses blagues,
la danseuse avec ses chorégraphies,
le chanteur avec ses textes,
le cuisinier, ses plats,
le photographe avec ses clichés.
Dans tous les domaines,
une part de magie qui peut intervenir
et c’est grâce à une certaine
magie qu’on en arrive à ça.
Que ce soit pour divertir une audience,
vendre un produit, fédérer une équipe,
la magie peut donc permettre de mieux
communiquer grâce aux émotions.
Alors, vous l’aurez bien compris,
on peut tous devenir des magiciens
à notre manière.
Il ne suffit pas juste de savoir
transformer un as de pique en 2 de cœur.
Il suffit d’arriver à pouvoir
provoquer une émotion chez quelqu’un
grâce à un domaine qui nous plaît.
C’est peut-être le chant, la danse,
une bonne blague.
Ça peut être un bon plat, une belle photo,
n’importe quel domaine.
Dans le domaine que j’ai choisi,
c’est la magie elle-même,
celle qui a changé littéralement ma vie
il y a près de 10 ans maintenant.
Et je peux vous le dire maintenant
sans prétention, je suis magicien.
Regardez, il y a 10 ans, des choses
me paraissaient complètement impossibles.
Je n’arrivais pas à faire,
je n’avais pas la bonne méthode.
Et grâce à la magie,
eh bien, je les ai réalisées, ces choses.
Maintenant, je parle devant vous.
Maintenant, l’impossible,
ça ne me fait plus peur.